髪の毛束にするのってさぁ、
んん...めんどくね？
束にしてもなんか、
風とか吹くとすぐ戻るし
髪の毛セットしてるやつら..よくするよ..
とてもじゃないけど髪の毛セット、めんどくさいから
無理です！
こんにちは  はじめしゃちょーです
昨日パッと見たときマホティーヌがとてもいいって企画をしていました。
youtuberのスマートフォンの中にある
動画を見ようのコーナーです
ある程度あのこっちの人がこれな人は、
なかなか思った動画出せないんですよ..
まあありがたいことなんですけども
まあ見て下さる人が多いとなるとこうなんか
ちょっと過激なことするとすぐ
バコォォン
なかなか難しいんすよ
僕の動画でもやっぱ知らない間に非公開になってるやつとかあるんで、
テレビみたいなもんですね
見る人が多いとねやっぱりこう影響力があるんで、
いろんな事に気を付けなけりゃいけなくなる
そうなるとねやっぱこう、
あーこれやべーなって思うことyoutubeにしにくくなるんですよ...
僕もね本当はねもっと
ダイナマイトとか使って爆破したいんですよ
人とか
嘘だよ？
まあそういうことも気にしつつ、ギリギリのラインで頑張っておりますので皆さんどうかこれからもよろしくお願いします
いやー本当に難しいよ
なのでその中でもねこのスマートフォンで僕もよく動画撮るんですけど
その中の動画は結構ねぇやっぱこう過激と言うか、
うーん...過激なことは映しちゃダメじゃん
あ、まった、ダメだ
過激な動画は出せないじゃん
過激なのはもう結局出せないんだね
一体はじめしゃちょーは普段どんな動画を撮っているのだろうっていうのをちょっとね、皆さんに今日ご紹介しましょう
ほんとしょうもないのしか無いですよ...
これはトミックさんを落とそうとするドッキリです
なんかTwitterでも上げました確か
(うわぁぁぁ!)
(はっは)
ふっｗ
あ、ご☆彡
これてつやが編集してるやつかな
なんでこんなん撮ったんだろうね
んーなんかyoutuberの裏の姿が分かりますね
編集を集中しないといけないから真面目にやってるんですよ
あのアホなてつやですらこんな顔して編集してるんですわけですからね
人差し指が長いですね
はっｗ
長いよ
あー困ってるね
(ルシファー)
ルシファー！
youtuberはね編集するときは集中しないとダメなんで
こういう感じになっちゃうんですよ
次！
これもTwitterに上げたな
(顎の怪獣め)
(っふふｗ)
(お前を倒しに来た)
これ仮面ライダーの変身してます
(おっｗ違うｗ)
(それ押すんだよｗ)
(変身!)
(あぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！)
(おおい！)
はっはっはっはっはｗ
あぁ自分の動画だった
なにこれ
(うわぁぁぁぁぁ!!)
(すみませんでした...)
これー...
トミックさんがなんか、
僕トミックさんに迎えに来てもらったんですけど
なんか電話しててめっちゃ電話先の人にめっちゃ怒られてるんですよ
え、もう一回見ます？
ほら　めっちゃ謝ってるんですよ
なんかきっと悪い重罪を犯して多分怒られてるんですよ
*笑い＊
あーダメだダメだ六面やめろやめろ
なにこれ
ふっｗ
笑ってますね
アバンティーズのりっくんと　えーと静岡の爽やかハンバーグを食べに来てた時なんですけど、
全然爽やかじゃないので動画を撮ってみました
爽やかハンバーグを前に
こんな爽やかじゃない表情は
滅多にないので
ほんとに、
ほんとに辛そうなんですけど
この後ゲロ吐きました
これートミックさんが僕んちに来たとき帰る時ですね
あーなんか静岡のなんかすっごい洪水レベルで雨が降った時があってそのとき雨がすごすぎて撮りましたこれ
ほんとこれだけです
(止まんないよー)
これはねメダルゲームに行った時なんですけどもめっちゃ当たってねメダルが止まんなくなった時です
あ、ペッパーの動画なんですけど
ペッパーの手を封じようと子供がね手握ろうとしてたんですよ
あーこれトミックさんが寝てる時のやつですね
と思ってたら起きてました
あーこれなんだろ去年の動画ですね
パイの実のなにか
パイの実取りました
覚えてねーなこれ
まさきだ
バカお前それは...
ははははっｗ
これね新幹線乗った時になんか
天気が良かったんで新幹線から撮ってるやつです
トイレに侵入しようとしてるな俺
あ、開いた
はっはっはっはっはっはｗ
あっはっはっはｗ
あっはっは(
あー犬だ
これね、カメラが壊れて修理に行った時にその
ソニーショップに行ったんですけど
ソニーショップに居たお犬さんの動画です
これなんだろ
わにぶんが家に来た時だ
自撮りして自分に酔いしれてる動画です
気持ち悪いですね
これなんだろ
トミックさん家でなんか火を燃やしてみた動画ですね
彼は寝てるんで気づいていません
これ寝てるそらちぃなんですけど
なんか寝言で応答してくれるんすよ
話しかけたら反応してくれるんすよ
（こんにちは）
ほら
（なんか喋って）
'%&'%('&)(&''#$%$==)8
wwwwwwww
何を言ってんのｗ
もはや夏バテじゃない
（そらちぃ）
（そこんとこどうなの？）
あーこれ
自分でたまに動画のやつをわざわざ作るんすよ
なんかタイヤとか付ける時
なんで　それをやってるシーンです
誰だ？絶対誰かいるパターンだこれ
うわあああああ
wwwwww
カリスマブラザーズのもんじゃですね
うっわもっじゃもじゃやんけ
これですねよっちと富山県に帰った時のやつなんですけど
僕がよっちに命令して
新幹線で暴れなさいって言いました
いやすごいね　やりたくなさそうだったんですけど
なんとかやらせたんで
こんな感じで
たまにiPhoneでもねYouTubeでも動画を撮ります
画面が綺麗なんですよ
ちんちん見せて
？？）ねぇ何で？
はじめ）ちんちん見せ...
？？）おかしいおかしい
はいとまあこんな感じでございます
なんかホントはねもっとね
ヤバいのとかもあるんですけど
これはちょっとYouTubeに見せられないのがあるんで
こんな感じでございます
youtuberのスマホの中とか面白いと思います
以上今日のメインチャンネルの動画でした
じゃあな